the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or nextar
Media Group
tonight on politics now election night
is just a few days away we break down
what you need to know on decision day
and what we can learn from early voting
numbers plus a new 8 news now Emerson
College poll what is on the voters Minds
come Tuesday and how the local FBI plans
to make sure the election is safe and
secure for voters
[Music]
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now I'm John langler so
election day is just three days away and
more nevadans are taking advantage of
early and mail-in voting about half of
the votes have been cast already we
spoke with Las Vegas Review Journal
politics and government editor Steve
Sebelius to break down the early numbers
so far
there seems to be this flavor among
Democrats I've spoken with that they
seem nervous
um based on the numbers you're seeing
and some somewhat's coming back in now
should they be
yes absolutely the Democrats should
definitely be nervous these these
numbers are not uh are not as
advantageous for them as they could be
um it's not as bad as 2014 in 2014
Republicans swept everything won
everything up and down the ballot uh
they were ahead in that uh at this point
with early email voting only at this
point in the election they were ahead by
about 25 000 votes uh in 2018 which was
the most recent midterm election uh the
Democrats were ahead by about 21
000 votes uh I'm estimating at this
point without the last day of early uh
voting in in hand the Democrats are
ahead by about 14
000 votes so it's not as comfortable as
it was in in 2018 but it's not as bad as
it was in 2014. what are you seeing from
maybe the independent voter and that
sort of turnout those early returns and
um what does that say potentially about
what we're looking at next week
yeah this election will come down in
large part to how The Independents break
in this election if they break 60 40 for
Republicans it could be a very bad night
for Democrats or I should say a very bad
two weeks because we're going to have to
quote account for a little while after
the election
um but if they break the other way for
for Democrats then it could be not as
bad as it otherwise would be I think
it's probably reasonable to expect a
mixed bag on Election night Republicans
winning some offices Democrats winning
other offices uh and I think the the
independent vote will largely determine
that because uh the parties are are
pretty uh are pretty uh stayed in their
ways they've got they've got their base
turning out uh but a lot of it will come
down to Independent voters who have
either left those political parties uh
because they were sick of partisan
politics or who aren't really interested
in partisan politics and how they
approach issues which could be
completely different from how you would
talk to your base voters here we are now
it's it's the weekend we're looking
ahead to election day your your
um Joe Lombardo your Adam laxel your uh
Michael McDonald you're on you're in the
GOP party and you're looking at how
things are shaping up right now
um what what are the expectations for
Tuesday uh what are the um
looking at numbers and crunching them
down where do you put your emphasis
where do you put your focus
uh I I think uh I I think the
Republicans have a very good chance in
the in the governor's race uh the the
um pandemic and how the pandemic was
handled by Governor Steve sisalak
affected a lot of people personally and
uh and and some in a very negative way
so I would be uh sweating it if I was
Steve sisolak
um if he wins that race it will be by a
very small percentage I'm estimating
that any Statewide winner is going to
win by fewer than 25 000 votes whether
it's Republican or Democrat it's not
going to be a landslide there will be no
going away elections down ticket though
I would worry as as we have seen in the
Emerson College poll and other polls I
would worry about the large number of
undecided voters in some of these
constitutional offices uh people don't
really know their state treasure they
don't know their state controller they
don't know for example what some of
these jobs do and uh and the fact that
they're just learning now I think is
going to be confusing for a lot of
Voters it'll come down to name
recognition it'll come down to the ads
that they've seen and whatever research
they have done on those races so I I
would if I were the Republican party I'd
be putting a lot of money into those
down ticket races uh to try to boost
turnout as well in the hopes that that
would also buttress the candidates at
the top of the ticket
now there are still some early mail-in
votes that need to arrive at election
headquarters and of course be counted
you can drop them off at any of the
dropbox locations in Clark County based
on eight news now Emerson College of the
Hill polling this week Republicans are
leading almost every major race in
Nevada and the Gap is getting bigger if
that comes true next week it would Mark
a major shift in state and National
politics
for Democrats trying to hold on to their
political careers the news is not good
the new 8 news now Emerson College the
hill poll shows in the Senate Republican
Challenger Adam laxalt leading incumbent
Democrat Senator Catherine Cortez Master
by Five Points 50 to 45 percent that
marks an eight-point gain for lack salt
from our last poll in September there's
also been a big swing among the key
Latino vote in Nevada laxalt leads
Cortez mazdo 54 to 41 percent that's a
huge change from September when the
senator led by 19 points Congressional
races follow a similar Trend with
Republicans pulling ahead in all but one
contest in District 1 congresswoman Dina
Titus is behind Republican Challenger
Mark Robertson by 10 points in District
3 Republican April Becker leads Democrat
representative Susie Lee 51 to 47
percent only in District 4 does
democratic incumbent Stephen Horsford
hold on to a slim three-point advantage
over Republican Sam Peters one major
reason Democrats are struggling is the
lack of support for President Joe Biden
55 percent of nevadans disapprove of his
work just 40 percent support the
president and a hypothetical runoff with
former president Trump Mr Biden would
lose
it's been close since the primaries
wrapped up Governor Steve sisalak trying
to hold off Republican Clark County
Sheriff Joe Lombardo however as the race
has dragged on polls show it's the
Challenger with the advantage our new
exclusive 8 news now Emerson College the
hill poll shows Lombardo leading by Four
Points 49 to 45 percent both candidates
have gained since our last poll in
September and undecided voters are down
to just 3 percent since our first poll
in June you can see how voters moods
have shifted while Lombardo held steady
before jumping up in October Governor
sisalak has gone up and down polling
also shows Governor sisalak losing among
Latino voters in the race for the open
Nevada Secretary of State Post just two
points separate the main contenders
Republican Jim Marchant has 43 percent
Democrat Cisco Aguilar 41 percent
Democrat attorney general Aaron Ford
leads his re-election bid 45 to 40
percent over Republican Segal Chatta one
thing which has stayed steady from the
very beginning though the issues that
matter most to nevadans as they vote
this November polling shows it's the
economy on their minds 46 percent say
it's the top issue with threats to
democracy a distant second as always
they're just polls only on November 8th
do these numbers become Real Results
and some reminders if you're going to
vote in person on Election Day Tuesday
November 8th polls open at seven o'clock
in the morning they will go until seven
o'clock at night if you're in line
before 7 PM you will get to vote you
don't have to go to a specific location
either in Nevada you can vote anywhere
in Clark County and you can do the same
day registration as well just make sure
you bring a proof of address we have all
the information you need for election
day at 8newsnow.com
Nye County's efforts to hand count its
ballots took several twists and turns
this week 8 news now was the only local
television station to get a first hand
look at the process in Nye County which
was shut down the ACLU is demanding now
an investigation by the Secretary of
State it says an observer from the ACLU
was removed by a woman who was legally
carrying a gun openly was carrying it
she removed the ACLU person from the
ballot counting area and eight news now
witnessed this the woman also demanded
the ACLU Observer turn over their notes
however that woman doesn't work for Nye
County instead she's the vice chair of
the Nye County Republican party
meanwhile Nye County's hand count was
shut down this week because workers were
audibly saying the votes and that
violates state law on the early release
of results Knight county has sent a new
list of procedures that would include
tallying the results in silence
well many of you have written to us
about some ads from a group called
citizens for sanity the GOP group's ads
show some of the most high profile
crimes Across America including the
recent stabbing on the Las Vegas Strip a
few weeks ago ad impact polling reports
they've spent 15 million dollars on ads
here in Nevada that's close to a third
of the group's total spending of 51
million dollars all across the country
next on politics now bringing in the big
guns the high-profile circuits helping
Nevada Democrats leading up to the
election and what the FBI is doing to
make sure the elections are safe and
secure
days on CBS
welcome back to politics now
this week Democrats brought out high
profile candidates for some campaign
help and the headliner former president
Barack Obama Victoria Saha was at
Cheyenne High School where he hosted a
democratic rally
[Applause]
voters coming out to see former
president Barack Obama who March Las
Vegas as one of his key stops around the
country to encourage not only voting but
early voting because this election
requires every single one of us to do
our part both the former president and
Governor Steve sisselek touched one of
the biggest issues at the center of the
political Spectrum women's Reproductive
Rights my opponents as Extreme as he
gets he supports a ban on abortions
what's the bad contraceptives and you
deserve somebody's gonna stand up for a
woman's right to make her own decisions
about her body and her health care
President Obama also focused on other
key issues this coming election day
including gas prices the need for
Affordable Health Care and housing the
former president in making it clear that
he wants Nevada Democrats to continue
fighting there may be a lot of issues at
stake in this election but the basic
question
that you should be asking yourself
is who will fight for you Senator
Catherine Cortez masto was also on hand
among other key Democrats audience
members also got a performance by artist
John Legend
Victoria Saha 8 News Now
in a statement the Lombardo for governor
campaign said as you see on your screen
there quote the sad reality is that
Steve sisalak would rather campaign with
Californians and out-of-state
politicians than fix the pressing issues
facing Nevada
Republican gubernatorial candidate
Sheriff Joe Lombardo cast his vote at
Mountain Shadows community center this
week his wife Donna there as well he
remarked how easy it was to get in and
vote he said there was no line
are we voting because we needed
something to change here in the state of
Nevada and that's the reason why I'm
running for governor because it in fact
some change here in the state of Nevada
when we have to address the economy we
have to address the education system we
have to address our Public Safety those
are the three tiers of my platform and
that's what I believe will bring Nevada
back in the right direction as a state
and within our great country
Lombardo also said he felt the state of
Nevada was doing a good job making sure
the election is secure and he says no
one should stay home because of polling
place fears
Democratic incumbent Governor Steve
sisalak was also up this week is early
at voting locations in Clark County and
as you can see he campaigned with New
Jersey senator Corey Booker on Thursday
unfounded allegations of Fraud and vote
tampering clouded the 2020 election well
this year there's one big threat for
federal law enforcement eight news now
investigator David charns spoke with the
head of the FBI's Las Vegas field office
about fighting misinformation and voter
intimidation
undermining of the election Integrity
itself is by far the biggest threat FBI
special agent in charge Spencer Evans
says the biggest threat to next week's
election is misinformation in lies so
the FBI is concerned because election
Integrity is at the center of what it
means to be an American and to be able
to have free and open and fair elections
the FBI and its local in-state
counterparts are looking at several
potential threats to undermine the
election they include voter intimidation
threats toward election workers outside
interference from a foreign power and
misinformation to suppress the vote
there's no credible information any of
those actions are underway right now to
the extent that they are that they can
be made safe I am confident that the FBI
and its Partners have done everything
possible to make fair and open elections
a reality for all in the violence
as the eighties now investigators
reported in August an independent audit
of the Clark County Election Department
found no issues regarding how Nevada's
largest county processes mail-in ballots
from their creation to their tabulations
Evans did not comment on specifics about
any threat Nationwide or here in Nevada
but says the FBI is watching in these
days to come and they will be watching
after election day even though this
environment is hypercharged politically
we need to make sure the FBI is
committed to ensuring that the rule of
law is followed and that we follow the
facts wherever they lead us I'm David
charns 8 News Now
since 2020 the Department of Justice has
worked harder to keep elections and poll
workers safe and if you see an issue you
should call the FBI's hotline which is
1-800 call FBI next on politics now how
National efforts to stop intimidation
and how law enforcement says covering
election day is different we'll talk
about that plus we're going to break
down the question that we're getting the
most how would rank Choice ballots work
this is politics
from all my heart
you're watching politics now
this week a judge in Clark County struck
down a request by the Republican
National Committee that tried to make
Clark County election officials hire
more Republican poll workers the
decision took place earlier this week of
course the judge says they didn't they
the judge says they didn't violate any
rules in hiring temporary poll workers
to verify signatures on mail-in ballots
a state law requires equal partisanship
Clark County argued it isn't a partisan
job so hiring wasn't based on party
the ballot question we get asked about
the most in this election season is
question three it would put in place
open primaries and ranked Choice voting
supporters say this would involve more
voters in the process both political
parties though oppose it they say it
would just confuse voters so here's an
explainer of how ranked Choice voting
would work
first it creates an Open Primary meaning
you can vote for anyone on the ticket
right now you can only vote for
Republicans if you're Republican Or
democrats if you're a Democrat
the top five would then go on to the
general election in the general election
you would rank them one through five if
someone gets more than 50 percent in the
general election they win if no one gets
fifty percent it goes to an instant
runoff the candidate with the fewest
votes gets eliminated their second
choice gets their votes and that
continues until someone has 50 percent
just a little explainer there as we head
to the ballot boxes meanwhile now back
to protecting the elections as you heard
earlier the FBI is concerned about voter
intimidation Washington D.C
correspondent Alexander Limon looks at
what's being done around the country
some officials are concerned about what
they see as a growing trend of
self-appointed poll Watchers going
Beyond peaceful observation being nearby
a box armed or dressed in such a way in
you know tactical or military type
clothing that can create intimidation or
concern for people dropping off ballots
Justin Smith is an elected Republican
sheriff in Larimer County Colorado Smith
says he felt compelled to join the
committee for safe and secure elections
because of the rise in voter and poll
worker intimidation the final nature of
these comments the explicit threats
Smith and other government officials say
the goal of these tactics is to
discourage voting or to pressure
election officials into changing results
the threats are driving many experienced
election workers to quit while laws vary
state by state Smith says if an action
seems inappropriate there's a good
chance it's also illegal in Colorado for
for example people are prohibited from
having an open firearm in unconcealed
within a hundred foot of any sort of
voting location Smith blames the
problems on Extreme political
polarization that he says is driven by
misinformation that spreads widely on
social media our elections have been you
know something that's really sacred to
us on either side when you lose an
election you've lost an election and you
move on and you honor that in Washington
Alexandra Limon
Alice Simone joining us from Washington
uh Alex let's continue the conversation
here about uh safety around the
elections uh you mentioned that the the
sheriff works with the committee for a
safe and secure elections can you tell
us more sort of about what that is and
and what they do
yeah definitely so the goal of that
committee is to bring law enforcement
and election workers and poll workers
together to start off these
conversations about safety and how to
improve it and so actually Sheriff Smith
told me that until he joined that
committee he didn't realize just how bad
this problem is and you know so he's
having one-on-one conversations with
poll workers and election officials from
all around the country and just hearing
just how awful how direct these threats
are against them and and how scary they
are for them and why it's driving so
many poll workers away from that
industry and so it's a really important
committee that kind of brings these two
entities together law enforcement and
then the election side of it so that
they can better understand each other
better know how to work with each other
to improve security things like that
what can specifically they do to make
sure that election day and leading up to
election day is safe and secure
well this sheriff in particular he's
from Larimer County Colorado and he said
that this whole experience has been
eye-opening and he said that for example
in his County when uh law enforcement
officials go through the academy for
example they learn about things like
traffic laws in general or you know
obviously murder different kinds of laws
Court proceedings even because officers
have to testify but one big thing that
they didn't learn about at least in his
experience in his County was election
laws and he says that's just so
important and they're so complex and so
you know detailed just depending um on
the state you live in or the county you
live in even taking photographs of
people walking in and out of polls that
could be illegal because you know voters
are supposed to be able to remain
anonymous
and that was Alex Limon there in Nevada
a reminder there is a state law that
prevents you from posting a filled out
ballot online it's illegal to post a
selfie for example on Election Day with
who you voted for filled in